what's going on everyone uh i want to uh
share a one-on-one
conversation they had with a buddy of
mine from high school uh who just
started his own business
uh and so he was texting me and uh he
was
he was saying hey you know i've got this
i've got this offer
and my value ladder and i want to get
your feedback on it uh and before i
looked at i said you haven't made a sale
right and he was like yeah
he said i'm worried about being stuck uh
with providing fulfillment because i'm
just doing too much and i'm offering too
much
and i was like right so you haven't made
a sale yet and he was like yeah
i was like okay uh you need to get over
that and i said what's the price and he
said 4 800 for 10 weeks and i said
listen man
just give so much that you feel like the
person would feel stupid
saying no all right don't try and fix
your non-existent
overwhelmed fulfillment issue when you
haven't even made a sale yet
all right close a deal then another and
then another
and then once you are overwhelmed you
then have the
then you can start dealing with it and
the benefit is that once you've made
sales
you will have the money from the sales
do you have resources to deal with the
problem
and so this is something that i see all
the time right people will
they'll try and solve issues that don't
even exist i have somebody like this
example right he's like
i don't want to be overwhelmed with all
this fulfillment i'm like dude you don't
you haven't even made a sale yet
right sell the world right sell
everything you possibly can to get them
to say yes
and then what happens is you're going to
start making money and then at that
point you can start peeling back the
the things that take the most time that
are not as valuable but in the beginning
you just have to create flow
so one of the rules that i always have
is create flow monetize flow
then add friction all right in that
order so once you have demand it means
you're making a good offer of some kind
then you are getting people to say yes
which means you make an offer that's so
crazy that someone would be stupid to
say no
and if that means selling your time
selling one-on-one stuff
doing flying out to their house or
driving over every day whatever it is
even if it's unreasonable
stop thinking about scale before you've
even had the ability to have a single
sale
right it drives me nuts because i'm like
dude you're trying to solve a problem
that doesn't even exist it's like
it's like when i would have guys who
come into the gym and they'd be like hey
well you know i want to get bigger but
i don't get as big as you and i was like
you're not going to sneeze and [ __ ]
get jacked
all right i was like there's a million
steps between where you're at and where
i'm at
and believe me it won't happen on
accident right
and so they're like well i don't want to
get to like they're trying to solve
problems they don't even exist i was
like why don't you why don't we start
with making you look like you even work
out
why don't we start there fair enough
right and the thing is
is like why don't we start with you
actually just getting a sale before we
even talk about
what your fulfillment optimizing for
profit even looks like right
and so anyways he sent me the big graph
of like what he's looking at and i was
like it's fine dude
just sell the world and deliver right
none of it's going to even matter
because they're not going to remember
any of it they'll just remember how they
feel
and how well you understood their
problems right
and if the solution felt unique easy to
understand
and easy to believe that it would work
for them right
um and so he he was like yeah it makes
sense it's crazy how much of this has
been like just removing my own
self-limiting belief and i was like yeah
money's made in your mind first right
poor people have poor beliefs
you can't if you're walking towards a
door right before you go and turn the
knob
you envision yourself turning the knob
everything happens in your mind before
it happens in reality
and if you can't envision yourself
actually making money doing it then
there's no way it's going to happen
poor people expect poor outcomes right
rich people expect rich outcomes
and they don't they don't accept
outcomes beyond that they don't make
decisions unless they feel like that
outcome is possible
right and so what happens is those poor
beliefs keep people poor
all right and so anyways i was like
listen man stop obsessing over whether
what you're gonna include or what the
little offer stack is
i say just give away the farm all right
make some sales and then when you have
money and a business then you can worry
about optimizing but for now you're
solving around a made-up problem that
doesn't even exist you have no
fulfillment issues
because you have no clients all right
sell first over deliver
and then optimize for profit all right
and so
this was just a process that i just see
is a mistake that i see happen so many
times
and if you were starting out sell
everything sell the most insane offer
you can possibly think of
get someone to say yes first all right
and then get another person to say yes
and if you're like man i'm so
overwhelmed that's okay you're supposed
to be overwhelmed
it's normal especially if you're
starting out all right but you're gonna
start learning
how even to sell right and you're gonna
start learning okay well this is
something that i'm
offering that might have been really
valuable in the sale but is actually
really easy to fulfill on and something
else that i promised out to fill on
they actually didn't care that much
about it but now it's taking all my time
and over time you can start peeling
those people pieces back
and making it into an offer that's both
profitable and attractive
to the prospect but when you're starting
out you don't know and so the best thing
in my opinion is to just
stack as much valuable as possible to
get them to say yes
all right and so what that means is you
don't have to be exceptional at sales in
the beginning because what you do is you
give something you give an offer so good
that someone feels stupid saying no and
so what i'll do is i'll wrap up with uh
i'll wrap up with the story of how i
learned this
and so when i was uh
23 i went to a conference
and i paid three thousand dollars for a
weekend conference and it was three
thousand dollars of money i didn't have
and it was it was run by a guy named
travis jones he went by tj and he was a
business coach and i remember when i was
there he'd offhandedly mentioned he made
a million dollars a year and i was like
i was like man i just want to be this
guy right i was like i'll do anything to
be this guy
and everyone there was a business owner
except for me and i was way over my head
they were talking about like ctrs and
conversion rates and
you know cost per leads and i was like i
don't know what's going on and so
anyways during one of the breaks he came
up to me
he saw that i was like way over my head
and he was like hey man do you want to
know the secret to sales
and i at this point i was learning what
the term sales meant i didn't even know
what it meant really honestly
um and i was like yeah yeah like tell me
the secret to sales
and so i like pulled my notebook out and
i was like i just like didn't want to
like miss anything
and he said make people an offer so good
they would feel stupid saying no
and for me it was this huge moment and i
underlined it i wrote it down i circled
it
and it was at that point that i realized
that i could still make money even if i
wasn't good at sales i just had to make
an offer that was good enough that they
would feel stupid saying no
and so that means if someone said no i
could keep adding things until
eventually they said yes
and that was one of the biggest
epiphanies that i had in my life was
realizing
that if i could just keep going and keep
adding value eventually they would say
yes
and so instead of cutting prices i would
keep my price
and just add more than anyone else could
even imagine so much so that it would be
ridiculous
and i was willing to scale the
unscalable in the beginning because i
just needed people to say yes
and start the flow right get the flow
monetize the flow then add friction and
so it was one of the most important
lessons of my life it's one that stuck
with me
through my entire career and in
remembering this is i'm now
getting you know i'm helping my friend
from high school i've got my my neighbor
who's starting their entrepreneurial
journey it's really reminding me
of some of these lessons earlier on and
i just uh hope i hope you don't mind me
just sharing them with you
as we go so anyways keep being awesome
lots of love i'll catch you guys soon
bye